[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we bring in the voice for Sunday Night
Football now at the Kentucky Derby he's
Mike Tirico joins us your track site
aren't you Mike
not a game not a game
with the first race coming up here in
five minutes
yeah here we go okay set the scene set
the scene Mike set the scene uh we have
the uh fans coming in everybody wears
pink on Friday because Saturday's the
Run for the Roses Friday is the best
race for the three-year-old Phillies the
Kentucky Oaks so everyone wears Pink
Ladies men hats the whole deal this has
really become like three days yeah they
made 15 some odd thousand yesterday so
over a hundred thousand today 150 000
tomorrow so uh this has become a bigger
and bigger deal like everything else in
America in life and it's uh it's a cool
usually festive scene there's a little
bit of you know concern and controversy
surrounding the race so it's an
interesting time here in the sport let's
dive into the controversy explain it and
how much coverage are you going to give
this on NBC this weekend
well we'll certainly talk about we're
going to talk about our coverage starts
on USA Today and we'll do it again
tomorrow a couple of times for sure so
four horses have scratch it was a
scratcher just a short time ago uh
Skinner scratch now
three of those scratches were kind of
normal horses scratching where
um whether it was the horse wasn't
training right uh got a fever had a
little bit of a concern with a muscular
issue uh the horse scrap one was a
little bit out of the norm and that's
where the controversy of it maybe the
conflict Discovery Lord mild crane by a
guy named sappy Joseph who had to trade
a couple of Derby horses before he's
from Barbados
his barn had two horses
died unexpectedly not related to racing
injuries nobody knew why the autopsies
were horses which were called the
properties aren't going to come back in
time to know what's going on so
abundance of cautions of people in
charge of Kentucky Horse Racing
commission suspended they scratched his
horse
and then the Churchill Down to the track
suspended Staffing Joseph and definitely
until they know what's going on Joseph
was upset by it I just think it's kind
of
an abundance of caution situations for
the track and the horse race commission
to make sure that horse doesn't run in
the race until they know what happens to
the other horses
how does that impact the derby
not a ton
um was Ward miles a favorite no 30-1
course the impact of the scratches is so
there's a pointless to get into Derby
the top 20 of the points let's get in
the derby all not all 20 automatically
running the Derby some say I'm gonna
hold my horse there's one blazing sevens
their connection so we're gonna hold
that horse to the Preakness but then you
go down on the list a little bit deeper
to get other horses in but not every
horse sticks around and comes here
waiting for five people to scratch so
right now we've gone from a field of 20
to a field of 19. a couple of the horses
who came in actually have a chance
Mandarin hero is one that's going to get
some betting attention I think but uh it
doesn't impact the field as
significantly because one of the big
favorites one two or three have
scratched at this point yeah it's not
like a Monday qualifier for a major in
golf you know where you're exactly let
me let me hang around here with my cat
my jockey and see if I can get into the
race well not too far from here John
Bailey famously as his eighth or ninth
alternate it yeah won the PGA
Championship right so there were a few
that were here and they have slid into
the field three of them as a matter of
fact but uh there weren't seven or eight
hangers they're horses who were like 24
26 on the list they are in other races
some on the card here some further down
the line uh Mike will be uh at the call
hosting the Kentucky Derby Saturday May
6 noon Eastern on NBC and peacock do you
pack differently
for this event
pair of shoes that
three of my six years I have left here
in Louisville because they're ruined at
the end because it's a little muddy
walking around and being in a bad
weather day that their shoes are gone
they are not salvageable but uh no not
really you know to bring some pink like
if you can't see as a thing I think for
today I've got something festive I
hopefully festive you know but typical
DP wardrobe a shirt with a little bit of
something to it class yeah although your
typical wardrobe now is a hoodie how
many hoodies do you want uh not enough
you can never have enough money give me
a number
yeah probably
it's good they're great they're great
yeah yeah as as
one of my kids or my French kids said
like all you old people are getting
hoodies that try to be younger and
you're not it just makes you look older
well how many blue blazers do you have
Mike yeah exactly
about saying I've got double breasted
I've got three buddies they're gonna
come back honey really they're gonna
come back I wear this on SportsCenter in
2002. it's not coming back do you have a
list of the celebrities who will are
expected to be there
uh partial list I know uh Mahomes is
coming Peyton's coming Aaron Rodgers is
coming I think Brady I'm not exactly
sure
um there are other names that have been
out there the parties what's happened
what's turned up a lot of the parties on
Friday nights at least you'll have uh
you know fans all that stuff three or
four different parties in town I never
get to see because we've had a seven
hour show on Saturday but uh I hear it's
a great time my wife came last year and
confirmed that it's a great event to go
to it's really enjoyable I'm like that's
great we're writing the 400s on the show
to talk about this horse and his human
connection it's all good hey I really do
want to come once as a fan have you been
as a fan yes one time it's great isn't
it yeah I went to uh the Belmont a few
times went to the Preakness a few times
as well
well the coolest part is it's a slice of
Americana you can't really see maybe I
could do some cheap camera work here so
I guess
no yeah this way yeah so over there yeah
that's good that's you can see it's
what's fires maybe that's what the
beautiful people say this is
Millionaire's world yeah over here yeah
and then over here to the other side
you've got the infield where people get
into like 20 or 30 bucks and they hang
they don't see much of the race except
on a big screen so you've got the whole
span right here and they're all betting
the races and having a good day most of
them don't come to any other races
during the year and that's what's made
this thing uh bucket list event for a
lot of folks can you just walk up and
buy a ticket
uh you know I don't think for the Derby
but today for the ocean okay even though
there are a hundred thousand I think you
can buy general admission I don't think
you can buy this they built a brand new
uh grandstand over here to my left with
six seven thousand uh right by turn one
so that's a it's a really neat place it
really is and this is this is as big an
industry as this state has urban and
horses whether it's the racing the
breeding all of that this is the
epicenter of it and well Louisville
Kentucky this is their pride and joy
they really they roll out the right
parts how long would it take you to run
around the track
right well it's a mile
so could you run it could you run the
mic
I can run a mile I don't think I can run
it in five in four minutes I think it
might take me a little bit longer like
right now if I just said would you run
the track and then I'll just put you on
hold
on oh right now well there are horses on
the track right now and there's a race
going on with Mike I think I'd be behind
them a little bit Dan
let me see erase one hang on a second
let me look at the board they ran the
first half mile in 48 and a half seconds
okay
we were uh mentioning Kobe's 60-point
game when he took 50 shots and you and
Hubie Brown were on the call
and I just remember I tuned into the
game you know just to say goodbye to
Kobe at least visually and I remember
you and Hubie Brown were saying we're
not really sure what to expect you know
maybe he could get 20 or 30. at what
point did you realize Kobe's going out
with guns blazing it's it's a funny
night I'll tell you about it I was just
talking so funny Brooklyn I was just
talking about that night with Mike
rapoli Mike is the owner of forte who's
the favorite in this race Mike and Kobe
were really tight business partners and
uh we were talking about that night
because the Lakers played I think in
Utah the night before how do you test
somewhere else they played the night
before and Kobe was trying to play as
many games as possible and we had the
pre-game meeting usually it's the coach
but Kobe came in the room because me QB
Lisa Salters did fiber shop our producer
and Kobe was like I don't know maybe I
have 10 minutes a half I'm yeah
I got nothing and then he started
scoring and he started scoring and
started scoring and there's a point
during the game where their free throws
on one end it's the third quarter focus
on the other end he's tugging on his
shorts and Kobe used to bite his bottom
lip when he was fighting through pain
kind of like this right and he's kind of
doing that he looks over at us it just
starts to crack a smile and he just kept
going and he'll be QB had a dream the
night before that Colton Smith scored
50. and he said I honest to God I'm
gonna tell you I just had a dream that
he that Kobe's gonna have a big night
and uh that's one of the favorite mics
I've ever been on TV that was just uh a
night to remember and then after Kobe
passed ESPN played the game uh he passed
on a weekend and they played the game on
a Monday night and I sat and watched it
I was on with Van Pelt afterwards on the
sports center and I watched the game
with the chills and just cried that was
such a memorable night and we did it as
a uh bouquet to Kobe's entire career as
the whole night went on and Ed feimshot
who's the hell of a broadcast I'm glad
it to the test of time because it was a
reminiscent of Kobe's greatness and all
these Great Moments and he gave us one
last one there as well do you save your
boards on every game that you do do you
have your your boards that you do to
prepare for getting home okay I do I've
got everything in a box that keep
meaning to go through them and I'm going
to that one I absolutely have I gotta
have a credential from that game and a
picture of me human Lisa Kobe and Eddie
shots that I've done that I've saved at
some point I want to pull out the
special ones I forget I was watching
somebody else it was Nance or somebody
and they said that they keep all the
yeah it was Jim uh talking about the
final four but he said that he keeps all
of the charts that he has had for all
the games so I looked at my wife and I'm
like you see it's not just me I've also
got a box of stuff that I don't look at
but uh I Hold On To those and make notes
on them Mike Mike some point look at
this building I have this is everything
I've saved I have press credentials from
1984 at the Boston Garden uh the the
1983 NFL draft like I I I don't know
what I would do if I didn't have a man
cave to put all this stuff in I I that's
what I need to do maybe I need to buy a
building like
is there an extra floor that I can
sublet from you you can store stuff here
if you'd like to if you give it to me to
split I mean Carson Palmer gave me his
Heisman for a year to display that's so
cool I don't have anything that good to
give you the display but I do like the
bottle there's that bob Knight in front
of you right no no no it's not nice that
is Lou Holtz
no everybody thinks it's bob Knight
because he's dressed in red and Lou
yeah the Colorado that's from Arkansas
that's fabulous yeah yeah I have my
little my little figurine in front of me
here uh have fun this weekend great
thank you all right I'm glad you're well
thank you Mike tariko Sunday Night
Football play-by-play and he'll be there
at the Derby and uh Saturday their
coverage starts at noon Eastern on NBC
and peacock